eight on your side gift cards they've  become more popular during the pandemic  you've maybe  experienced them yourselves but  unfortunately that also means they're  popular with scammers  listen to this the federal trade  commission says since 2018 americans  have lost  245 million dollars paying off scammers  with gift cards  anybody that asks them to buy a gift  card for  any sort of business thing and read the  numbers off is running a scam  no legitimate business or government  agency takes payment with gift cards  that's steve baker with the better  business bureau which says  losses from gift card scams across the  u.s have tripled in the last  four years